اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد شاب
فلسطيني برصاص قوات الاحتلال في مخيم
بلاطه شرقي مدينه نابلس والجديد نتابعه في
مخيم بلاطه بشرق نابلس كما ذكرنا مع
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري ماذا في
التفاصيل جبار
بعد اقل من ساعه ازدهار سيشيع جثمان
الشهيد فارس الحشاش الذي استشهد برصاص
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انطلاقا من
مستشفى رفيديا في مدينه نابلس وصولا الى
هنا نحن الان ازدهار وحسن كما ترون المشهد
يتحدث عن نفسه نحن امام المنزل الذي
حاصرته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بدءا
بوحده مستعربين ووفق شهود العيان اكدوا
لنا ان بعضهم كان يلبس اللباس صحفيينه
وهذا ما يثير الان الريبه لدى الكثير من
الصحفيين بان يتم استغلال وضعهم وايضا
كعمال النظافه وصلوا وحوطوا وطوقوا هذا
المنزل وهذه المبنى الصاروخ الاول الذي تم
اطلاقه كما نرى استهدف سياره
المطلوب الذي يبدو انه تعتبره قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المطلوب الاول لديها
مقاوم الذي الان يعلن عن اسمه رسميا بانه
عصام الصلاج وتمكن للمره الثالثه من خلال
حتى عمليات عسكريه كبيره في اقل من شهر
ونصف من الهروب وفشلت الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه من الوصول اليه كما نرى ايضا
المبنى نحن في داخل مخيم معناه المنازل
متراصه قديمه متهالكه لكن القوات الاحتلال
قامت على الاقل وفق شهود العيان باطلاق
ثلاثه صواريخ انيرجا القناصه كانوا
يتواجدون في كل المواقع يطوقون المنطقه
ايضا كانوا يتواجدون في كل الازقه
والحارات نحاول ايضا الدخول الى المنزل
المنزل هو المستهدف في الطابق الثاني ولكن
المبنى كله بالكامل اصبح الان ايه للسقوط
حاله من الرعب بالطبع تسود هنا كافه ارجاء
المخيم ولكن في ذات الوقت ما نسمعه من
الاهالي تصميم على مسانده كل المقاومين
الفلسطينيين وبالطبع من بينهم عصام الحلاج
وهو احد الصلاج عفوا عصام الصلاج وهو احد
قياديين كتيبه مخيم بلاطه كما نرى الرصاص
اطلق ويستطيع الان الزميل راجي ان يرينا
حجم الدمار ليس هذا الطابق الارضي نحن
نتحدث عن الطابق الثاني فكيف سيكون الوضع
في الطابق الثاني الان يصعب الدخول الى
ذلك المسكن لانه اصيب بحاله صعبه جدا شكرا
يعني في وضع خطير لا يستطيع احد الدخول
اليه فقط يعني شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من مخيم
بلاطه شرق نابلس مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
البديري